digamos que tengo la serie s que no es
otra cosa más que una suma infinita de
términos genes y esto es por supuesto
van desde n iguala o no hasta infinito y
recordemos que esto sólo es una forma
compacta de decir que estamos sumando a
uno con a 2,3 y así por siempre porque
porque es una infinidad de términos de
verdad y ahora digamos que tenemos la
fórmula de las enésimas sumas parciales
verdad digamos no sé que a lo mejor
tiene la fórmula 2 n cúbica entre n 1
por n más 2 muy bien entonces a partir
de esta información te hago la siguiente
pregunta y que deberías ver si puedes
responderla por tu propia cuenta será
cierto que la serie converge o por el
contrario será que la serie divergen
porque a lo mejor es lo que está
ocurriendo es que estamos sumando tantos
números que esta serie o esta suma
infinita crece y no está acotada verdad
o pues al revés qué
esta serie converge algún valor
específico verdad así que una forma de
resolver este problema o quizás una
forma de pensarlo es que la serie que
tenemos originalmente no es otra cosa
más que el límite cuando n tiende a
infinito de las sumas parciales verdad
entonces lo que estamos diciendo aquí es
que puedes imaginar una sucesión de
números que está dada por las distintas
sumas parciales s1 s2 y s3 y así
sucesivamente entonces aquí estamos
sumando sólo a uno aquí estamos sumando
a uno más a dos
aquí estamos sumando a uno más a dos más
a tres y así vamos con esta sucesión de
términos que están dadas por las sumas
parciales entonces a medida que aumenta
estamos sumando más términos y quiere
decir que estamos atendiendo al valor de
esta serie muy bien entonces la pregunta
es qué pasa a la larga con las s n
y otra forma de pensarlo es como que
esta serie ese es la suma de los de la
primera infinidad de números quizás no
tiene tanto sentido pues también una
forma de pensarlo muy bien entonces si
esto que estamos diciendo es como
estamos calculando el valor de esta
serie pues podemos simplemente sustituir
la fórmula que nos habían dado verdad
entonces tenemos el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito de 2n cúbica entre n 1
x
+ 2 muy bien y aquí por supuesto uno
puede rápidamente ver que en el
denominador hay un polinomio de grado 2
verdad si uno hiciera el producto de n
más uno por ende más 2 nos queda un
polinomio de grado 2 en la variable n
verdad y el grado de ese polinomio es
menor que el del numerador que se me
cúbica entonces quien va creciendo más
rápido es el numerador y eso haría que
este límite tiende a infinito es decir
que no está acotada esta sucesión de
sumas parciales verdad ahora quizás esto
lo dije muy rápido vamos a hacerlo con
más calma ok primero multiplicamos el
denominador esto es el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito de 2n cúbica entre n
cuadrada más 3 n
+ 2 verdad sería la suma de los términos
constantes y después el producto muy
bien
ahora bien calculamos este límite lo que
vamos a hacer es dividir en el numerador
y en el denominador entre n cuadrada
entonces qué es lo que tenemos límite
cuando entiende infinito d
si dividimos 2n cúbica entre n cuadrada
nos queda 2 n la hora n cuadrada entre n
cuadrados 13 n entre n cuadrada es 3 / n
y 2 entre n cuadrada pues es eso
2 entre n cuadrada y ahora si nosotros
aplicamos este límite arriba esto
tenderá a infinito verdad 2 n tiende a
infinito mientras que en el denominador
lo que ocurre es que esto tiende a 0
esto también tiende a cero y entonces
todo el denominador tiende a 1 verdad
entonces ya hemos visto algunos ejemplos
de estos límites cuando tenemos esta
situación podemos garantizar que el
límite
es infinito nada más que lo voy a pintar
bien muy bien entonces el valor de la
serie es infinito es decir estamos
diciendo que esta serie divergen muy
bien esta serie s tiene un valor
infinito es decir estamos diciendo que
divergen no está acotada muy bien así
que si el límite hubiera tomado por
ejemplo un valor
finito entonces si podríamos decir que
la serie converge verdad lo único que
estamos diciendo en este momento es que
si tenemos una fórmula de las sn de las
sumas parciales entonces la serie la
podemos ver como el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito de esas sumas
parciales y entonces simplemente tenemos
que calcularlo y si por ejemplo en este
caso el límite tiende a infinito la
serie divergente